كان الناس يزدادون بدانة وكنا
أقل نشاطًا ، لذلك اعتقدت جيدًا
أنه ربما هناك طريقة لحل هذا الأمر ، وهو
جلين جيزر يدرس آثار
التمرين بالنظر إلى عدد السعرات الحرارية
التي تحرقها أثناء القيام بأشياء مثل
المشي وبعد ما يقرب من 50 عامًا من البحث
الذي حصلت عليه  فكرة رائعة لدراسة جديدة
من أحد عروضه المفضلة Monty
Python the flags
أنا من أشد المعجبين بمونتي بايثون ، أعني أنني
لا أرى كيف لا يمكن لأي شخص أن يكون
معجبًا بمونتي بايثون وبالطبع
وزارة سخيفة  كانت مناحي إحدى
المسرحيات التمثيلية المفضلة لدي ،
أي شخص شاهد الفيديو
يعرف أن هذا الأمر يبدو وكأنه نشاط بدني جيد جدًا
، وأنا وزملائي في الأساس
خطرت لي هذه الفكرة ، فلن يكون من الممتع أن
أرى فقط كم كانت هذه المسيرات السخيفة مكلفة للغاية في
الواقع.
السعرات الحرارية التي أحرقوها ، أرى أنك
مهتم حقًا بالسير في المدينة ، أليس كذلك
روب ، لذا أجرى البروفيسور جيزر
دراسة كان لديه في البداية 13 متطوعًا يمشون بشكل
طبيعي وبعد ذلك يبذلون قصارى جهدهم
لتقليد  تمشي أكياس الشاي السخيفة
والسير بيو دي مشيًا ، لقد شاهدوا
الفيديو ضاحكًا قليلاً كما
تريد حقًا أن أقوم بهذه التهوية
وسيسجل تبادل الغازات
لقياس مقدار الطاقة التي استخدموها
وحساب عدد السعرات الحرارية التي أحرقوها.
الكثير من المرح معها
في واقع الأمر ، كان بإمكاني سماع بعض
الضحكات تحت قناع الوجه
أثناء سيرهم ، استغرق الأمر نصف
قرن للوصول إلى هذا الأمر ، كما
تعلمون أن عمل حياتي كان يتطور
إلى هذا الحد واستغرق الأمر  بعد فترة طويلة من
قياس نتائج الدراسة ،
اتضح أن مستر بيوتي ووك يكاد يكون
مكثفًا مثل المشي بمزيد من المال ،
لكن المشي في كيس الشاي اتضح
أنهم كانوا يحرقون السعرات الحرارية بشكل أساسي
بمعدل ضعفين ونصف ضعف معدل
المشي العادي.  وهو أمر
غير عادي حقًا لإعطائك بعض
المنظور حول أسلوب السير على شكل أكياس الشاي ،
كان في الواقع مكافئًا أو
مشابهًا جدًا للجري بسرعة حوالي خمسة أو
ستة أميال في الساعة إذا قام شخص ما
بالتقريب  كل 11 دقيقة يوميًا من
المشي عالي الطاقة على غرار أكياس الشاي ، فإنهم
سيفيون بإرشادات الصحة العامة
للنشاط البدني القوي ،
كما تعلمون ، هذه دراسة روح الدعابة
ولكن الفكرة هي محاولة جعل المشي
أقل كفاءة ، وقد تكون هناك طرق يمكن
للأفراد من خلالها  من خلال خيالهم الخاص
يمكن أن تجعل حركاتهم
أقل فاعلية قليلاً ، مما يسمح
لنا بإنفاق المزيد من السعرات الحرارية
وبطريقة لا نضطر في الواقع إلى القيام
بمزيد من النشاط البدني